de que la participación está siendo alta
al menos en la capital esto podría ir en
beneficio de cuál de las dos posturas en
esta pugna en el en el plebiscito
bueno lo que se estima luego de los
resultados del plebiscito de entrada es
que a un nivel mayor de participación
más o menos continúe en esa misma tónica
sabemos por los resultados del voto en
el exterior que hay una diferencia entre
un 10 y un 20 por ciento entre quienes
aprobaron en el plebiscito de entrada y
quienes están aprobando en el plebiscito
de salida pero claro con un nivel de
participación mucho más alto per s sería
la tendencia si las encuestas hasta
ahora indican una fuerte división social
en torno al texto cuál es la razón por
la que una mayoría progresista que llevó
a boricha al gobierno luego de las
masivas protestas podría ahora no verse
reflejada en un sí a la constitución
bueno ahí quiero hacerte un matiz creo
que lo que se está viviendo en chile es
un proceso de repolitización y de
democratización de el debate público en
torno a esto que es trascendental como
es la carta magna de un país diseñado
con una convención constituyente por
tanto lo que es esperable es que el
debate en torno a la misma visibilicen
posiciones y creo que lo que pasa es que
chile se está viendo un poquito
convulsionado por retomar un nivel de
diálogo que había perdido por décadas y
que después del retorno de la democracia
no había logrado reinstalar claro y en
caso de que se vote hoy que no a este
nuevo texto por idg dijo que se deberá
nombrar una nueva constituyente habla
usted precisamente de que hay debate un
nuevo debate político en chile que
debería hacer una nueva constituyente
para conseguir dotar a chile de una
nueva carta magna que dote al país de
más consensos
mira en principio si ganara el rechazo
creo que se produciría un periodo de
muchísima incertidumbre porque hay que
tener en cuenta quienes se posicionaron
la opción de restar sólo durante este
último tiempo no han logrado presentar
una verdadera propuesta coherente creo
que hay que respetar que la ciudadanía
pidió un proceso constituyente en el
2020 este se llevó a cabo de forma
completamente democrática paritaria y
representativa en cómo está constituida
la sociedad chilena
en verdad
solo se abriría un periodo de
incertidumbre de ganar el rechazo pero
de todas formas como tú dices el
presidente ya aseguró que volvería a
llamar un proceso constituyente y ahí lo
que habría que afinar es cuál sería la
característica de esta nueva
constitución sin embargo lo más probable
es teniendo en cuenta el que sería la
victoria de alguna forma del discurso
más conservador que lo más probable se
quede en un status quo porque es difícil
en este panorama de lograr una una
verdadera transformación constitucional
qué es lo que el sector más amplio del
rechazo postula